lemon had John fetterman on John
Federman as you know he's the Democrat
lieutenant governor of Pennsylvania
running against Dr Oz he had a stroke
six months ago the guy is having trouble
speaking but putting aside the stroke
and not and not to mock any of his
language stuff or any of that his ideas
are all terrible they all are about
releasing more criminals he loves all of
the woke stuff oh like he is like sort
of Ground Zero Democrat like if it's if
it's all bad it is encapsulated in this
guy and on top of the fact that he can't
speak here he is with Don Lemon talking
about inflation well let's talk about
inflation because that's a big concern
for voters what do you think the biggest
cause of inflation is and should the
Biden Administration be doing more
no I I just do I I think that that
simply is also we have this talk about
the trillions in in massive tax uh tax
uh cuts to the corporate uh tax
structure as well true
oh
you know maybe I was a little too harsh
maybe maybe he is making some sense and
I should come around to some of these
ideas uh here's a gratuitous for uh one
for you here's just some awful moments
from Don Lemon I'm not listen again I'm
not a political person I'm a person who
lives in reality I'm a journalist the
Republican party is obsolete we cannot
sit here and pretend like well you
Republicans and so cut them a break
unless we want to hear what if they have
a lot to answer for right now our
democracy is endangering it's because of
one party and that's the Republican
party they are the party of everything
that they're trying to pretend that
they're not the people who are in
Charlottesville that's not us yes it is
you what are they essentially saying
that they don't trust people who don't
look like them we have to stop
demonizing people and realize the
biggest Terror threat in this country is
white men and we have to start doing
something about them there is no travel
ban on them there is no white guy band
so what do we do about that the only
party now that is operating in reality
is is the Democratic party just
objectively speaking it's like oh my
gosh Nancy Pelosi is a boss people who
Us New Yorkers we've known who Donald
Trump was for a very long time you think
about the Despicable people we've had in
history okay now I'm going to use an
extreme example
um think about Hitler anyone who is in
that white house and who is supporting
him is complicit in their racism is the
president declaring war on Americans
open your eyes America open your eyes we
are teetering on a dictatorship and
let's not forget if anyone is judging
this I'm not judging this our country
was started because this is how the
Boston Tea Party
rioting
can we just clip that do I even have to
add anything like what is the point I
mean the guy is just awful the funniest
part of that I mean we were all cracking
up throughout it was when he said uh
there is no white guy band and Conor
over here who happens to be the fairest
skinned of all of us you kind of freaked
because you know he'd come for you first
you know what I mean I've got a little
more color Phoenix is a little a little
more olive skin but a white guy like you
if lemon had his way
band